I stopped taking it after we fucking broke up
to give my my body a break from the hormones!
I don't think you understand. Like, I-I
seriously can't deal with this right now. I have-
Okay. Okay. Danny, I'm sorry it's so stressful for
you.
Stop!
That's not what I meant.
Why are you yelling?
Because I'm fucking frustrated! And we're both yelling!
You yelled first.
Clare, I can barely pay rent. And the band...
I can't be in South America when you're
having a baby, Clare. I can't.
South America?
Yeah. Brazil and Argentina.
What? Shit.
We're just-
Danny. Shit.
the openers.
It's not- well, first of two openings.
It's nothing. What am I talking about?
I feel like a fucking asshole talking about my band
right now. Who cares about my band?
I care about your band. You care about your
band. And you should.
I love... I love your band.
I love you.
And I don't want to be some cliché of an
absentee father, either.
My family will fucking disown me.
Yeah, that's... that's not the same as loving me.
I do love you.
You fucking know that, Clare.
Okay, um...
The timing is terrible. Obviously. Yeah.
We're not even together.
Like this isn't that hard to figure out.
I mean, this is how we got back together. We
always knew this would be the reason.
Exactly.
I'd have to give up music. I'd have to- I'd
have to get a desk job or wherever gives benefits.
Like, what are my skills? What can
I even do? I'm gonna have to go back to school.
Get a fucking degree.
Danny, stop!
Just stop for a second!
It's okay.
No, it's not.
It's okay. We broke up for a reason, and we
need to go out.
And we need to live our lives. You go on
tour, fucking kill Argentina. Fucking kill Brazil.
I'm going to- I'm going to go to
Iceland and climb a glacier or something.
I'm going to live my life. And I think you
should live yours.